قبل فتره صرح انه يكد لا يتحدث مع بقيه
افراد اسرته الملكيه وعلى الاخص والده
وشقيقه اكبر لاسباب ربما لا يعرفها سوى هو
زوجته ميغا والان وعبر مسلسل الانتفلكس
ظهر الامير هاري مهاجما عائلته ومعلنا عن
بعض الحقائق الصادمه الامير يقول ان
عائلته المالكه تسرب قصصا عن بعضها البعض
هناك اشخاص يعملون بالقصور الملكيه يشربون
الاخبار للصحفيين بل وصل الامر للتوفيق
واختلاف القصص وصفا ذلك بانه لعبه قدره
لكن قصره لكنها لم يعلق على تلك التصريحات
ومن المتوقع صدوره كتاب للامير سيتحدث فيه
عن معاناته بعد وفات والدته الاميره ديانا
خاصه بعد زواجها من ميغان التي طالما وجهت
انتقادات حاده للعائله المالكه واتهامات
بالعنصريه وهو مكان فيه العائله الملكيه